(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This is
the Fiji Banded Iguana,
a creature as stunning as it is rare.
Native to the tiny Fiji
Islands in the South Pacific,
it is one of the most geographically
isolated iguanas in the world.
Vibrant like a jewel, these
reptiles are considered
a national treasure by
the government of Fiji.
Their emerald green colored
skin is sensitive to light
and can change color to
match its background.
The males like this one are
banded with blue streaks.
Their long, spiny toes end
in claws to help them climb,
but none of these adaptations
can protect this species
from the many threats it faces.
Habitat loss from development,
poaching for the illegal pet trade,
and introduced predators like
rats, cats, and mongooses,
all cloud this creature's future.
This is the Fiji Banded Iguana.